وحول هذا الملف ينضم الينا في الاستديو
الزميل عبد الله العالي عبد الله مرحبا
واهلا بيك عبد الله على ضوء تصريحات
ماكرون هل باتت فرنسا مستعده اليوم لارسال
طائرات اف 16 الى اوكرانيا
تصريحات مكروه ليست هي الاولى التي يدليها
يدلي بها مسؤول فرنسي والرفيع همم
ليقول من خلالها بان مساله همم بيع او
تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتله لم تعد
امرا محظورا وانها اصبح بالامكان تداوله
بشانها والحديث عنها لانه قبل ايام من
تصريح ماكرون كانت هنالك تصريحات لرئيس
لجنه الدفاع الوطني والقوات المسلحه في
الجمعيه الوطنيه الفرنسيه اي مجلس النواب
الفرنسيه في لندن وقال فيها بالحرف الواحد
بان كل الابواب باتت مصرعه فيما يتعلق
بتزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتله واردف
قائلا بانه في بهذا الشان لم يعد هنالك اي
موضوع يدخل في دائره الحظر وبات بالامكان
الحديث في كل شيء همم لكن تصريحات مكروه
جاءت متطابقه في المعنى مع مع ما قاله
رئيس لجنه الدفاع الوطني في مجلس النواب
الفرنسي لكنه كما شرط الى ذلك قبل قليل
همم غادي ارداف ذلك بشروط منها اولا ان
تقدم اوكرانيا رسميا هذا الطلب والامر
الثاني لا يكون الامر تصعيديا والامر
الثاني الامر الثالث الشرطه الثالث بنسبه
المكرونه لا يضعف ذلك قدرات الجيش الفرنسي
على حمايه الاراضي الوطنيه
على الامدي القصير لان الطلبات الاوكرانيه
الان هي قبل كل شيء من فرنسا تحديدا هي
تزويد اوكرانيا
بانظمه دفاع جوي ومدفعيه وهذا الامر
تستجيب له فرنسا على نحو كبير اما بالنسبه
للطائرات فلم يحسم امرها بعد ولم تطرحها
حتى اوكرانيا بشكل جدي بالاضافه الى ايضا
انه هنالك مساله اخرى خلال المباحثات بين
البلدين ويمثله التزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
من طراز لكنها وهي قضيه ايضا لم تحسم لان
همم هنالك عسكريين يقولون بان فرنسا لا
تستطيع ان تزوده بتلك الدبابات لان ذلك قد
يضعف امكانياتها الذاتيه للدفاع عن ارضها
طيب الا يتعرض ذلك برايك عبد الله مع
الموقفين الامريكي والالماني
هناك بالتاكيد تبعي لا لا شك فيه انه يوجد
تباين بين الموقف الفرنسي كما صيغه على
لساني الرئيس الفرنسي ورئيسي لجنه الدفاع
في جمعيه الوطنيه الفرنسيه وبين الموقفين
الالماني والامريكي الحالي لان وزير
الدفاع الالماني قال بالحرف الواحد بان
تزويد بالطائرات مقاتله ليست من الوارد
اطلاقا وهو الامر الذي اكده المستشار
الالماني ايضا اولى فولت حينما قال بان
هذه المساله غير مطروحه حتى همم لكن
بالنسبه للموقف الامريكي هناك هذا الموقف
الذي ورد على اللسان جودا الرئيس الامريكي
والذي قال فيه بانه لا يعتزم تسليم
اوكرانيات تلك المقاتلات وبين ما ورد قبل
ذلك بايام على لسان نائب مستشار الامن
القومي في اداره نفسها الذي قال بان هذه
المساله ستبحث وتدرس بعنايه فائقه خلال
الفتره المقبله وايضا يتناقضوا مع ما صدر
عن الشريكه المصنعه لطائرات افسته عشر
التي تطالب اوكرانيا بتزويدها بها والذي
قال بان مصانع التابعه لشركه ستقوم في
الاسابيع المقبله بزياده انتاجها من اجل
ان تلبي بشكل مرضي تماما اي طلبات تصدر عن
دول تريد ان تزود اوكرانيا بتلك الطائرات
في الفتره المقبله اذا هناك نوع من اللبس
في في الامريكي
16 من قبل الغرب هل يحوله الى طرف مباشر
في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه الغربيون في
البدايه كانوا يقولون بان اي تزويد
لاوكرانيا باسلحه دفاعيه واسلحه ثقيله
سواء كانت صواريخ او طائرات مقاتله او
دبابات مقاتله همم قد يؤوله من قبل روسيا
على انه همم خلق
لمساله عدم همم التورط المباشر انه يفضي
الى جعل تلك الدول او تلك المنظومه
الدفاعيه ويعني بها حلفه شمال الاطلسي
متورطه بشكل مباشر في الصراع الدائري
حاليا في اوكرانيا لكن التاويل الغربي
ويختلف لان التاويل الغربيه يقول بانه
يجوز للغرب ان يمول اوك يمول الجيش
اوكرانيا وان يسلحه وان يدرب وان يزوده
بمعلومات الاستخباريه وان كل هذه الافعال
لا تجعل من الغرب طرفا مباشره في النساء
دائره هناك بالمقابل هنالك خطاني احمران
تريد الدول الغربيه ان تلتزم تلتزم بهما
حتى الان
وهما همم اولا ان لا ترسل قوات عسكريه
غربيه ترتدي زيا عسكريا غربيا الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه والامر الثاني ايضا لا تسمح
لكيف بان تستخدم الاسلحه التي تزودها بها
من اجل ضرب اراضي في العمق الروسي اي داخل
حدود روسيا المحترف بها الدوليه ولكن
الغرب يعتري يعتبر ان من حقه تماما ان
يساعد اوكرانيا بكافه الوسائل من اجل
الدفاع عن ارادها ومن اجل تحرير الاراضي
التي تحتلها روسيا حاليا شكرا جزيلا لك
عبد الله العالي على هذه المدخله